hey everyone i'm excited to be here to
discuss how you can speed up your
software development with better
insights and deeper diagnostics with new
capabilities have been jointly developed
from the bigquery and cloud logging
teams
i'm christopher crosby i'm a product
manager focused on advanced analytics
here at google cloud later i'll be
joined by charles from the cloud logging
team
so a fundamental requirement for
enterprises wanting to transform
themselves digitally is a need to store
manage and analyze large quantities of
operational data from a variety of
sources
logs are critical
data source for troubleshooting machine
learning data analytics security so
while cloud logging today can already
handle massive amounts of data
capturing petabytes with ease
many developers they still struggle to
analyze this log data and they're unable
to find those symptoms in the log that
lead to deeper diagnostics and despite
the large volumes of data often they
still find it hard to move from a
retrospective log analysis
to predictive insights and prevent
issues before they happen
so to help you achieve this next level
of software development with better
insight and deeper diagnostics charles
and i are thrilled to announce log
analytics a new comprehensive easy to
use cost effective and performant tool
within cloud logging that has the
performance and power of bigquery behind
it
this capability should help you use your
login data for both better diagnostics
as well as getting more insight into
your business
now with the companies i've worked with
i've seen several teams that rely on
logging data
yet the majority of the users really
struggle to analyze that high volume of
law of messy that log data and that
leaves organizations with a lot of
unrealized potential
so the new log analytics feature is
directly targeted at those teams who are
wrestling to extract insight that they
need from that hard to analyze login
information
this is targeted at devops teams who
want to improve system reliability and
they might be struggling with analyzing
logs at large large scale and want a
centralized logging repository or i.t
teams that need insight into how to
better manage their fleet and they're
struggling to analyze signals across
multiple clouds or even data centers and
look at the trends over historical
amounts of time
security teams that want to identify
attacks and they want to start taking
advantage of the latest and greatest
machine learning and advanced analysis
techniques to detect those threats
or business users that want to make
better decisions today they struggle to
get logs integrated with their
visualization and analytics tools and
they struggle to combine their logs data
and business data
now when i go and talk to these teams it
becomes pretty obvious what the source
of their struggle is
what makes log analytics hard today
is the complexity of the data systems
that organizations need to run
so most of you watching you're probably
familiar with a similar convoluted
architecture at your own cutting where
possibly application logs they go into
an elastic index and then that's where
your application performance monitoring
or cabana dashboards are but then you
have lower level operating system
network logs that flow into a
proprietary security vendors database
then of course there's other machine
generated logs like maybe from sensors
or iot data and they get stored in a
format that's optimized for time series
analysis which is then down sample
remove data warehouse
and so there is a lot of overhead with
all of this and you definitely pay an
additional tax
for extracting and copying all that data
around
so when i chat with the end users of
these systems
they tell me that today's common
architecture patterns
it generates five critical issues that
make this log analytics so hard
first
is the latency issues there's just a lot
of additional hops and that means data
takes longer to get to different in
systems
two
there's no clear source to true
data transformations they might happen
in multiple places that makes it a
challenge to understand what's happened
to the data
three
moving to machine learning requires a
lot of additional hoops
it is not trivial to just take a
tensorflow model or a notebook and put
that on top of these various systems
or the reliance on multiple interfaces
where the same users need to learn
different systems that just has a whole
mess of different applications and tabs
that users have to manually reconcile
themselves
and even with all this user pain the it
teams still have to manage a lot of high
cost and management complexities of
running all these different vendor
databases and applications
when i ask customers what they want it
essentially boils down to having a
separation between the log aggregation
and the log applications
more of our tech savvy customers have
already started to adopt bigquery as a
centralized log aggregation store for
data collection normalization and
storage management tasks like auditing
and compliance
now here at google it does seem
intuitive to us
that customers are choosing bigquery as
their next generation log log analysis
platform
dremel which is the query engine that
bigquery is based on
that was originally designed and built
for logs and it's been used for over a
decade for analyzing logs and creating
sophisticated machine learning on those
logs for some of google's biggest
applications
search youtube gmail
and so if i start to compare bigquery
against typical logging platforms that
customers are using today
there's some clear advantages that i'm
seeing
first is just the management
today's logging platforms need more
automation just due to the application
shifting into ephemeral servers and
microservice architectures it's just
becoming way too hard to keep up with
all the various it management tasks that
are required for running the various
logging backings bigquery fully managed
serverless
two
customers need data lake scalability
logs they're coming from all over now
on-prem multiple clouds kubernetes real
world iot systems what used to really be
a telco scale for a lot of these
security vendors that relied on logs
data
it's pretty standard for your average
enterprise now and when it comes to
security analysis
you need these logs in a centralized
place
threats are not system specific the
hacker got in gcp
guess what they probably got into aws
too and you want to review and track
that in one location
it's equally important to also have a
full history of the logs that's becoming
more important if you look at something
like the recent solarwinds attack
that went back over nine months it
doesn't work anymore you just have 30 or
60 days worth of logs in your security
database
you need something that can cost
effectively and independently scale the
storage and analysis like bigquery can
and speaking of security you know the
security posture that many of these
legacy or on-prem log systems had
they relied on security controls like
maybe the network as a primary layer of
protection
but now in our cross-cloud world things
like network parameters are vanishing
and you mix that with tougher
regulations like gdpr it should you
really need a back-end now that can help
you achieve the security posture it
makes it easy to align to our digital
life world and that you can trust with
your login information
another big one that i'm really hearing
from customers is the need for advanced
analytics and custom ml
customers are finding that these
pre-canned outlier dashboards that their
logs applications are coming with
they just don't cut it for the systems
today i was working with one enterprise
who moved over their existing sem to gke
and almost instantly about 30 000
erroneous alarms so customers have told
me that they want to do their own
analysis develop their own algorithms
that are designed for their architecture
their business
bigquery is already being used by some
of the largest security vendors out
there to develop xdr platforms as an
alternative to reactive approaches of
the set
and they're doing that with gcp ai
capabilities like bqml and vertex
finally
there's just a lot of new use cases that
customers want to use
that customers are realizing
customers they understand now that
there's a lot of business value in
joining all this logging data to their
business data and then they want to
share with others
i'm working with an e-commerce company
who's analyzing weblog data alongside
their clickstream data to better
understand how users interact with their
site and then they can offer them better
product recommendations and that's
already led to increased sales for them
so having logs that can be easily
analyzed and joined to the rest of your
warehouse that just opens up a whole new
set of use cases like predicting
customer behavior optimizing online
marketing campaigns maybe even
understanding how employees engage with
different software solutions in your
organization
so to unlock these use cases and help
customers better understand the logs
data that they bring to bigquery
we're enhancing support for log
analytics with investments in three core
areas semi-structured data
search indexes and time series analysis
these new features and functions are
going to let you explore and analyze the
wealth of logging data that you have
alongside your business data
so with native json there's going to be
a new data type specific to json and
it's going to on a load shred that json
document that can be unstructured
constantly changing into a columnar
store format so you can get the same
performance and cost effectiveness that
you come to expect from any other
structured data in bigquery
along with that you're going to find
additional json functions like a dot
subscript notation to make it a lot
easier to work with these json data sets
second the search indexes are going to
provide text indexes that provide users
the ability to run what i call needle in
the haystack type queries on the log
data
this is when you want to pinpoint a very
specific
data element so let's say i want to find
chris crosby in a petabyte of blogging
data so i can delete him for gdpr
reasons this search index is going to
let you do that or find specific ip
addresses or other
specific data elements finally coming
soon is there's going to be also time
series joints and data types so we're
going to support joining tables by
arbitrary time
time windows
we sample that data and you'll also be
able to store time periods as opposed to
just a point in time
so here at gcp we're putting our money
where our mouth is and we're standing
behind these features in our own logs
applications
we are using these features as a base
for our log analytics application from
cloud logging and so now i'm going to
hand you over to charles to tell you
more about that
thanks chris
my name is charles baer i'm a product
manager in cloud logging and chris and i
have been partnering on log analytics
the log analytics combines the purpose
build logging platform provided by cloud
logging with bigquery's powerful data
analytics platform and we build log
analytics in cloud logging for three
reasons
first ad-hoc log analysis to empower
users to answer sophisticated questions
where ad-hoc grouping can deliver useful
insights
for log aggregation to answer the types
of questions that require log
aggregation over large data volumes and
to build a platform upon which both our
users and our product can grow for the
future
now cloud logging is uniquely positioned
for log analytics
cloud logging provides an integrated
logging solution both for services that
are running on top of gcp as well as
logs that are generated externally
this includes log collection routing
storage and analysis all the things you
need in a logging platform
so in cloud logging log collection is
really easy logs for services on google
cloud are automatically collected and
it's easy to collect other
infrastructure and application logs if
you need to and getting the right logs
is easy
it's a first critical step for the
logging analytics as well
second thing is the logs router provides
powerful routing capabilities
the built-in routing routes logs to
cloud logging other gcp services like
cloud storage and even to external
third-party tools with integration
through pub sub
now for log analytics the platform
routes logs to bigquery
the storage platform provides a scalable
log management capabilities these
capabilities provide controls around
what logs are stored where they're
stored how long they're stored and who
can access them to meet your compliance
requirements
for login analysis this manages the
storage and access in bigquery
cloud logging already provides several
tools to analyze logs each with special
purposes
the logitech floor is a tool optimized
for troubleshooting use cases with great
features like log streaming a log
resource explorer and a histogram for
visualization
if error reporting which helps users
react to critical application errors
through automated error grouping and
notifications
and through log base metrics dashboards
and alerting which all provide other
ways to understand and make your logs
actionable for operational use cases
our new log analytics feature expands
this tool set to include ad hoc log
analysis capabilities
taken together cloud logging provides a
powerful platform specifically designed
for working with logs
so what is log analytics exactly
log analytics extends the capabilities
provided by cloud logging in several
important ways
first log analytics automatically stores
logs in bigquery with a simple
configuration set
with a check box enable log analytics
when you're creating a log bucket you
can use cloud logi's pipeline to make it
easy to store those logs which you can
then analyze in log analytics
second we're excited for a new
purpose-built log analytics ui which
provides access to the logs using sql
now sql is a well-known widely used
domain specific language has powerful
aggregation capabilities and of course
it's widely used in bigquery
when you need to group buyer sum or find
a ratio
log analytics supports the same standard
sql functions provided by bigquery
now the log analytics ui provides an
optimized results experience designed
specifically for working with
unstructured log data and you'll see
more of this experience in the demo
later
third logs included in log analytics are
made available directly in bigquery
users need to join logs with another
data source they can run the same query
and log analytics ui and the bigquery ui
and join that data with data already in
bigquery
so by making this log data available
where users need it log analytics can
help remove data silos
so how can you benefit from these new
capabilities
log analytics can help reduce the need
to send logs to so many different
systems to address the separate use
cases
i'll cover three common use cases as
examples first is for the devops team
resolving issues quickly is critical to
maintaining system reliability
especially when user facing services
log analytics helps here
by helping users more quickly find
patterns by correlating ids across
services so that you can reduce outages
more quickly
faster troubleshooting can also help
improve the speed of software
development by reducing time spent on
debugging and therefore freeing up
developer time
the second is security
investigations are a critical part of
understanding and remediating security
threats log analytics can help here by
finding logs across large time ranges
which often means large data volumes
the third is it operations managing a
fleet of different services is a core
part of it operations and it's important
to understand the events and trends
across the whole fleet
log analytics helps here by identifying
patterns and the fleet performance over
time
now there are many ways that log
analytics can help enable business
decisions including analyzing business
data reported in logs
and by unlocking valuable insights log
analytics brings new value to your logs
and now since there's no better way to
show off a new feature
let's see a demo
in this demo i'll show you the new log
analytics ui an example of combining
data stored in log analytics with other
data in bigquery i'll highlight the
capabilities offered by log analytics to
address two use cases one is the devops
troubleshooting use case and the other a
security use case
for the demo i have instances of the
online boutique which is an open source
microservices demo and it's deployed to
two gk clusters which are generating
logs which are ingested into cloud
logging
using the out of the box configuration
i've set up a logging sync to capture
the logs and send them to log analytics
enable bucket and cloud login
with a click of checkbox logs are
available both in log analytics in cloud
logging and in bigquery first let's look
at the log analytics ui which is a new
ui in cloud login optimized for viewing
logging data in the log analytics ui use
the same standard sql that is available
in bigquery sql queries you use to view
the log data and can range from simple
or complex
there's a query builder here where you
can enter your sql in a results viewer
to view the query results to start let's
take a look at the completed kubernetes
logs for the front-end service
over the past hour
once the query is valid i can run the
query
now the log analytics ui
provides
two specific optimizations that have
been added to bigquery and used by log
analytics the first is the json value
function which allows you to extract
json data and compare it to strings
which is really useful and for queries
like this or when you want to look at
the string results
of data stored in json
and the second optimization is the json
dot notation
notice that the json payload message
field is actually using the dot notation
to refer to a field inside the json
structure of a json payload both of
these make it easier to work with json
data
the results are displayed using a view
optimized for working with log data you
can see that the json payload is
actually stored as json data which means
that any json structure data can be
stored in there without having to know
or specify the schema up front
the log analytics ui the json
data is actually displayed using json
pretty print format to make it even
easier to use
now by looking at some of these logs
i notice that there is a value inside
these logs which is the
response took milliseconds
which is the time the request took to
complete
so one of the things we can do is look
at the min max and average values of
that over time
these kind of queries can be very useful
when troubleshooting so let's take a
look at what this would look like
there we go
okay so what we're doing here is we're
extracting this field and we're casting
it as an integer so we can do the sum
we're also taking the hour and then what
we're doing is we're grouping looking at
the minimum the maximum and the average
value
what we notice by looking at the results
here is that around hour 14
both the maximum as well as the average
time increase substantially
so this gives me great insight during
troubleshooting and it can help me more
quickly identify the signals which can
help me resolve issues more quickly
the log analytics provides the
flexibility to look at individual logs
as you've seen and run complex
aggregations which can help surface
critical insights for the devops team
when troubleshooting an issue
now let's take a look at the security
use case
again staying with the same scenario the
app deployed to gke this time let's look
at the security related logs for
application and infrastructure
we can do that by using a query like
this
the main difference here is that we're
looking at the photo payload field here
and we're looking for audit logs
so why don't we run the query
here's what the audit logs look like in
login links
you can see that they are the record
type within bigquery
and you can see that there's a detailed
structure of the audit log
within the frodo payload field
there's a lot of information that's
stored within an auto log
and it's actually displayed in the ui
using the json prepaid format to make it
easier to work with
all of the fields that are actually
stored as a record type are also
displayed using the json data type to
make it easier to work with
again
what's more interesting is to look at
the aggregations so let's take a look at
the audit logs grouped by the principal
and the ip address fields which are the
users as well as the ip address from
which those
actions
originated
great so now we can see
the both email address and the ip
address and the number of calls that
have originated from both
now for security use cases sometimes
it's useful to search for a value in a
log without knowing which specific field
the newly added search function in
bigquery allows you to do just that
the function searches across an entire
table or set of columns to find a value
to demonstrate let's pick an ip address
and find all the audit logs associated
with the ip
across any field in the table we can do
that by using the search function
specifying the table as well as the ip
address defined
so by using the search function i've
been able to find all of the records
that are associated or include this
particular ip address this is
extraordinarily useful for unstructured
data that is stored in json in other
fields
for example it's not limited to ip
address or just for audit logs can be
used generally across any of the fields
within bigquery now one of the powerful
features of log analytics is it also
provides you with access to the same log
data in bigquery while logging links
provides an optimized ui and one that
revolves add more optimizations having
access to log data in bigquery means
that you can join the log data with
other data in bigquery by clicking the
run in bigquery link in log analytics
the same query is loaded in bigquery
and running that will return the same
results with the standard bigquery
formatting
you'll notice it's the same data however
the results are
appear differently for the protocave
format
now in bigquery we can combine that ip
address data that we looked up in the
previous example with other data
as an example i'll combine the ip
address
with a public data set and use the
functions in bigquery to produce a list
of all the countries and the number of
logs for each
i can do that with this
query we have the
select statement which will look at all
of the audit logs over the past 30 days
and select the i p addresses from them
as well as the account and here i will
join that data the public data set as
well as use the bigquery ip functions to
be able to get the country associated
with each of those ips
so by combining the audit log data with
the geolocation public data set
i've been able to gain insight into the
requests coming from different countries
most of the requests have come from the
united states i do see that other
requests have originated from places
outside these united states this
combination
can provide powerful insights
so to recap log analytics and cloud
logging provides a powerful way to
analyze your logs based on the power of
bigquery the log analytics ui provides
an optimized way to view and work with
log data
and the log data stored in log analytics
is made available directly in bigquery
for joining with other data
while we're excited about log analytics
we're already hard at work making it
both easier to use and more powerful
to make it easier to use we're working
on adding a new visualization result
type via charts so that users can more
easily understand their query results
we're also working to simplify the user
query experience we know that not
everybody's a sql expert which is why
we're making
working to make it easier to gain the
benefits of login analytics without
becoming a sql expert
we're also working to enable log
analytics by default this will make it
easier for any users to access the
advanced logging capabilities
now to make log analytics even more
powerful tool we're working on logging
in sites logging insights can surface
data that you would otherwise have to
search to find by analyzing data
proactively login analytics can help
uncover powerful insights such as
proactive recommendations
we're also working on to expand the
scope to include other operational data
by combining logs data with other
operational data such as trace data you
can gain even more context for a more
rich analysis
we're really excited about what
launching the log analytics feature
today
and we're excited to see the powerful
ways that you'll use these new
capabilities
so on behalf of the whole cloud logging
bigquery teams thank you for watching
to learn more about log analytics and
cloud logging please visit our docs and
sign up for the preview to get started
you